this is titled help me conan
and it's by rocketbook official
a fan on instagram suggested i reach out
this way
i'm having an issue with my husband he
wants to name our son
conan after you at first i thought he
was joking but as we progress
i realize he's very serious the issue is
i have red hair
and he has a lot of hair sort of like
you so this could be really creepy
we had a deal a while back that i get to
name the baby if it's a girl
and he gets to choose the name for a boy
maybe you can talk him out of it
please well you've come to the wrong
person i
say i totally with your husband here i
think the name
conan is not used no one uses this name
and i don't know if i've ruined it or
whatever but it's a valid
beautiful first name with like a great
you know sort of gaelic
anglo-saxon heritage and i don't know
i i don't know why more people don't use
it and i'm starting to feel a little
self-conscious that i've
ruined the name i think conan the
barbarian may have ruined it
yeah oh i think so i'm sorry did you
what did you want to ruin it
i kind of didn't want to be the one who
ruined it
it does that's the size of my ego is
that i'm
hurt that i'm not the one who ruined
conan
uh maybe this will make you feel better
but obviously my whole life i only knew
it as conan the barbarian and then when
your show came
on like everybody it took a while for
that to seep in and then when i started
working for you
conan was so clear to me that i then saw
the movie
conan and kept calling it conan the
barbarian right
right yeah it's funny uh i remember that
movie came out i think i was in
college the first when the early college
maybe
freshman year and i went and saw it and
no one had ever really heard my name
before
because none of us really knew the comic
books and then this movie came out and
i'm in the theater
and you just heard all these characters
saying
conan conan and i had never heard my
name
outside of someone addressing me yeah um
and of course it was all i will kill you
i'll rip your head off that stuff i had
heard
right from various siblings and
neighborhood thugs
and parents parents nice and
grandparents
i'll crush you um but i still think it's
a great name
and uh i think if you it's kind of like
that old johnny cash song a boy named
sue
where the character is named sue and
people tease him for it but then he
turns into like the toughest son of a
[ __ ] ever
yeah i think if your son has red hair
and a lot of it and combs it up in a
pompadour and his name is conan
he's going to work so hard that he will
eventually
because he'll have to he'll have to to
surpass
and rise above the tor the torture and
the teasing
he will eventually um become famous
that and he will replace conan and conan
o'brien
he'll replace us both right and then
he'll be the new conan
and that's what needs to happen oh this
needs to happen is that your son
needs to pick up the mantle and become
the most famous conan of all did people
make fun of you
with your name yeah yeah they did when
the when the movie got really popular
okay trying to think wouldn't make me do
i didn't work out i know i was gonna say
it
it didn't you didn't have the sue effect
it's not like you became
super tough no like i don't want to hurt
your feelings but
no no i developed a razor sharp wit now
i didn't
really either do that i know you think
it's more just i made
i learned how to make a lot of faces and
move my hips around in a strange way
what do you think this new conan will be
known for if it goes barbarian
comedian something yeah what do we think
it could be
what's this new conan gonna do that
makes him
the most famous conan of all well there
is a singer named conan gray
who's pretty popular right and there was
conan nolan the broadcaster right that's
right
conan nolan yeah but they slip by the
wayside
this conan gray guy is he really coming
up on me fast
he is i mean you know the real trick is
to like
type in conan on google and see which
name comes up first
i'll do that right now no you know what
i don't
what if it's not what if it's not
o'brien
then this is awkward well let's find out
if this conan gray is coming up fast on
me
conan o'brien yes and second place is
conan
gray okay so i'm still first and then
conan the barbarian right conan the
barbarian so conan gray is still
in second position we've man i'm
i'm gonna sweat this now yeah and how
popular is he pretty popular right he's
got a great face
okay all right so okay sorry oh so my
face is all [ __ ] up no i mean no he's
like a
he's like a cute right singer right he
doesn't have like beady eyes and
thin lips and come on you're winning can
you just take that
i'm i'm barely ahead right now is this
like some young cute guy is that the
idea yeah
i'm sorry
show me a picture of this conan gray
this is upsetting i've worked hard to
build this conan name
look at look at his face that's a great
face
there's a picture of him with a raven on
his shoulder oh my god this guy is so
much better looking than me
and you know what he has a look of
intensity yeah
that i can't manage you're better
looking than conan the barbarian
what um well yeah no
no no we are no yeah conan the barbarian
you
what are we talking about we're talking
about schwarzenegger in his prime was an
adonis
he was yeah no i'm i'm really just
trying to be nice right now i'm getting
right now i'm talking about
conan the barbarian now oh the aged
conan
conan now hold on a second hold on a
second i'm looking at these pictures of
conan gray
you really are scrolling i'm really
scrolling and there's a lot of pictures
of him
we're very different he's got oh there's
a picture of him biting into
an apple ah see i can't look like that
biting into an apple i'm just usually
like oh good apple
this guy's really looks there's a
picture of him
from equate magazine biting into an
apple and he looks like
he means business he wants to get that
top spot on google
i need my fans to rally you know the way
beyonce has these fans who whenever
someone
threatens beyonce you know or says
something about beyonce
she has the beehive the beehive i want
that the cone drones the cone drones
thank you thank you oh yeah that's as
cool as the beehive they're both bees
you know you're not
can you do me a favor you're not helping
we're onto something good and you're
just like an anchor
dragging off the back of our race car
sorry i'm helping uh
listen matt i'm serious the cone drones
this is fantastic it's you picture an
army of like orange drones
i just want them to go i just we got to
chip away at this conan gray thing
because i look at this guy he looks he
looks like a million bucks
i hear that he sounds great i can't
compete with that i'm i'm rotting like
an old pumpkin in the sun
and this guy is coming up fast i think
there's two ways to handle this what you
either have the cone drone
army google your name to raise it higher
in the ranks
or google conan the barbarian to surpass
conan grey no no your second idea is
stupid
your first idea is genius i need the
cone drones to drive me way up high in
the google search
so that conan gray fades like the gray
light
at dusk you want to destroy this young
man's career
not destroy it he can do other things
do they still have coffee shops he
wanted to work at like a
kingpin office yeah there's still things
he can do
he's got a whole life ahead of him how
many years do i have left one
50. we don't know but conan gray is here
to stay
well here's the thing that's weird is
that it started off with this
this person asking if they should name
their kid conan you said please
you said let's make you more famous that
kid's going to surpass you on the google
list you know what can i just say
and i don't mean to i'm you know this
woman
reached out and asked me for a favor but
we've got bigger things to worry about
now
and i can't be i can't get bogged down
in your problems
name the kid conan don't i just got to
jump out of this one it's the conan gray
thing
you've now made me aware of that has
triggered my fight-or-flight reflux
okay and i have to do something okay i
have to
i gotta get the cone drones to put me
ahead of conan gray
i just had a horrible realization what
what happens
when you go gray-haired people are gonna
google
conan oh i know well that's why i'm
buying all these wigs
i bought all of lucille balls old wigs
at the balls
estate sale i have 600 lucille ball
vintage wigs
that i got at the estate sale and i'm
going to start applying them
you're going to see me 1950s lucy 60s
lucy
here's lucy uh lucy's back you're gonna
see all
stone pillow lucy when she uh did her uh
star turn
uh as a homeless person sure i remember
that yes
i have that way thank god it's not a
great wig but the point is
i'm set i've thought ahead about this
and conan gray it's nothing personal
uh it's just you or me man it's you or
me and i've got to win
okay okay the other realization i had is
just us discussing this is going to make
every listener go what's this conan gray
look like
that you didn't happen yeah yes oh no
and then they're gonna look him up
you know what don't i will say you
should no no no
no no don't there's something i noticed
a virus or something on that
on that on that google search i'm not
sure i know exactly how computers work
but
i'm getting yes a text now oh this is oh
god i can't believe this is too bad for
the kid
yeah there's a virus when you look up
his name and
that gets right in your phone it's
already got into my phone and a blue
foam is coming out of it now
i wouldn't go on that but uh it says
here if you
oh if you google conan o'brien oh that's
cool huh
yeah you get a free uh krispy kreme
donut
well rocketbook official i hope we
helped
yeah i'm sorry i forgot your problem
sorry i didn't really listen
uh good luck with whatever's happening i
think it involved a human life